actualizamos la información económica en
directo a América con Daniela Blandón
Daniela saludo nuevamente Hola Ángela y
ya se conoció el dato de inflación de
Estados Unidos que estábamos esperando
acaba de salir Ángela Pues el índice de
precios al consumidor en Estados Unidos
aumentó 6,4% en el primer mes del año
esto después de haber cerrado 2022 con
un alza del
6,5%. Esta es la menor cifra desde
octubre de 2021 y también aunque los
precios siguen cediendo todavía el
incremento anual es más del triple de
ese 2% que quiere lograr el Banco
Central Y aunque parece que el alza
consecutiva de tasas de interés de la
reserva Federal sigue teniendo efecto
porque vemos como los precios están
bajando no lo está teniendo al ritmo que
se necesita ya que la Fed va a completar
un año incrementando ese costo de los
créditos y la inflación apenas se ha
desacelerado en menos de tres puntos una
encuesta de rotors con los operadores
del mercado encontró que más de la mitad
cree que esas tasas van a seguir
subiendo al menos dos veces más en los
próximos meses y en medio de ese
panorama en el país las grandes
multinacionales siguen despidiendo gente
sí Ángel al turno esta vez es para El
fabricante de vehículos Ford que acaba
de anunciar que despedirá a uno de cada
10 empleados en Europa concretamente
anunció que planea eliminar 3.800
puestos de trabajo en los próximos tres
años la mayor parte de ellos en Alemania
y en Reino Unido en su momento el
director financiero de la firma
Automotriz aseveró que la productividad
de los ingenieros en Europa era un 25 o
un 30% más baja de lo que debería ser y
es que Ford está buscando una mayor
eficiencia de costos a medida que
fortalece su negocio de vehículos
eléctricos algo Bastante necesario ahora
porque justamente hoy el parlamento
europeo acaba de aprobar la prohibición
de los coches de gasolina y diesel a
partir de 2035 esto para hacer esa
transición hacia los vehículos
eléctricos y bueno vamos a cambiar de
región en Argentina se anunció un
control de beneficios para abaratar el
precio de la carne Si el Ministerio de
economía cree que con esta medida
algunos cortes populares de carne verían
caer los precios en alrededor del 30%,
todo esto en medio de una inflación
general que en todo 2022 fue de casi el
95%. la cartera de economía dijo que
había llegado a un acuerdo con los
frigoríficos y con los supermercados
para incrementar la oferta de siete
cortes parrilleros de carne en el
mercado doméstico esto desde este
viernes de esta manera entonces podría
adquirirse a precios menores a los
actuales hasta en un 30% esto también
hasta finales de marzo después de esa
fecha Viene un nuevo recorte de precios
que esta vez era del 32 del 3,2% hasta
el 30 de junio de acuerdo con datos
oficiales los precios de la carne
aumentaron entre el 54 y el 78% el año
pasado dependiendo de la región y vamos
a ir al otro lado del mundo en Turquía
que seguimos recordando hay cálculos
posible costo económico del terremoto si
hay cálculos del gobierno y cálculos de
los gremios ankara ha calculado el daño
en 50.000 millones de dólares pero la
confederación turca de empresas y de
negocios dice que el peor terremoto en
casi un siglo en ese país podría costar
más de 84 mil millones de dólares de ese
total más de 70.000 millones se
necesitarían para reparar las viviendas
afectadas otros 10.000 millones serían
pérdidas de ingresos nacionales que
desde que ocurrió la tragedia y unos
2900 millones también se habrían perdido
en días laborales ya el presidente está
ahí perdoana ha dicho que el estado va a
completar la reconstrucción de viviendas
dentro de un año veremos si es así o no
y recordar solamente este dato en esas
diez provincias afectadas por el
terremoto
vive el 15% de la población de Turquía y
allí se produce cerca del 10% del pib
Bueno no es poca cosa Ahora vamos a los
indicadores en pocos minutos va a abrir
Wall Street pero el mercado estaba
bastante animado con esta noticia de el
dato de inflación en Europa las bolsas
operan alentadas por datos de desempleo
en Francia en Reino Unido en donde las
tasas del cuarto trimestre de 2022
fueron de 7,2 y 3,7% respectivamente las
bolsas asiáticas cerraron con ganancias
con excepción de Hong Kong en Japón el
académico
fue nominado por el banco del gobierno
para hacer el próximo gobernador del
Banco Central y también le tengo
indicadores de medio oriente porque la
libra libanesa alcanzó Este martes un
nuevo récord A la baja en el mercado
ilegal donde ya se cambia a 70.000
unidades por cada dólar el Banco Central
Ángela había aplicado comienzos de mes
una subida del 895% al tipo de cambio
oficial entonces pasó del 1500 a 15.000
libras por dólares sin embargo es muy
lejos de esos 70.000 a los que se está
cotizando hoy Daniela Muchas gracias Nos
vemos mañana con más noticias Pero por
supuesto que sí